my name is amar Klein I'm a freelance
software engineer working most of my
time which contain analytics and today I
will be talking about running point in
the browser so I think it's evident that
the web is getting more important in
many areas of our lives including how we
publish scientific results especially in
the last few years we got html5 and
JavaScript has much improved so we can
make our visualizations and our
applications much more interactive and
that means that we can create a much
richer experience for our end users and
you know this is a good thing because
this means that we can come we can in
some cases convey our ideas more
effectively and we can let our users
explore the data in novel and
interesting ways so this is something
that we should embrace there are say
however one problem and that is that the
language of the web is JavaScript and
JavaScript kind of sucks I think that
anyone who has done some programming in
both points and Java scripts can relate
to these photographs if you program in
white and everything makes sense then
you become happy and most parts of the
language have been well designed and
this is much less the case in JavaScript
and you know it's especially for Python
programmers this contrast is pretty big
much higher than for instance for
programmer who programs in PHP and I
think this is the main reason why there
are so many projects that try to bring
peyten to the browser in one way or
another so in order to give sort of an
overview of of these different projects
and that's who understands how they
relate and how they differ I categorize
them or I grouped them in three
categories projects that are transpilers
projects that are basically an
interpreter written in JavaScript and
compiled interpreters so turn in a
transpiler
you would start with Python code offline
and you would transpile that to another
something that can
execute into the browser most often it
will just be JavaScript one example is a
rapid script which is the pre compiler
for JavaScript similar to to
CoffeeScript and PI scripts is a project
that I've been working on and will be
telling you more about in the second
half of this talk and basically it takes
part in code trance policies to
JavaScript but it's implemented in
Python which makes that you can for
instance write a Python module but write
a couple of functions in the same part
in modules but these will then be
executed in the client instead of
important so it's it's it's suited for a
more pythonic workflow the advantage of
the this group of projects that
transpile Python code to JavaScript is
that you're basically really writing
JavaScript using a Python syntax well
the advantage of that is that it's
pretty fast because an integer will just
be a JavaScript number and a string will
be a JavaScript string so things are
faster but of course it's also
disadvantage to some extent because it's
not as pi tonic as it could be in the
category that our JavaScript based
interpreters these are projects that
basically have an interpreter a Python
interpreter written in Java scripts and
the two most well-known projects that do
this are scopes and brighten sculpt is
more aimed at being used for educational
purposes so letting people online learn
parts and by writing code in a browser
and route and brighten is intended to be
used as a substitute for JavaScript to
develop web applications in this case
this is more real part in in that an
integer part an integer is behaves much
more like a part an integer and not a
JavaScript number and the string is
really more like a Python string which
is on one end it's a good thing because
you know it's more genuine Python but
because you have boxing it's also much
slower so these projects are typically a
hundred times slower than the C part and
interval
turn also well it takes a little bit
more memory to get him loaded as a
library and the last third category are
the compiled interpreters the most
well-known example is pipe ijs which
basically is a project where they take
the took the pipe I source code to pipe
is an interpreter and yeah a parts an
interpreter implemented in a slightly
different way using a JIT and it runs
far much faster than regular C peyten
and they took that source code and they
compiled it to to a sort of subset of
JavaScript using the LLVM
tool chain and inscription and the the
advantage of this is that I didn't have
to write a lot of code so it should be
relatively easy to maintain they took a
project that already existed and make
that work in the browser and for
instance a few months ago there was a
new version of pi pi that was much
faster and they just had to really
recompile things and then their projects
is faster as well so this solution is
actually faster than C Buyten there's
also a technology called pinnacle which
stands for portable maths portable
Native Client which is a Google solution
so it's only for Chrome and some people
have demonstrated that they can actually
run peyten plus numpy in the browser
using that technique however it's chrome
only so probably you know it's not
something that we'll see a lot of in the
future I would say but there is some
exciting other developments going on
namely web assembly so web assembly is a
standard that people are working on for
executing native code in the browser and
this is something that will be adopted
by all the big browsers and I expect
that when death becomes available there
will definitely be people implementing a
Python interpreter using that approach
so the advantages of this approach is
that it's it's it's real Python and it's
fast but disadvantage or the main
disadvantage I guess is that it's quite
rare
- at least the in Piper GS Francis the
the virtual machine alone is over 13
megabytes so it's not not something that
you would easily embed in your
visualization then there is like a
fourth category maybe that of frameworks
so and these are mostly based on top of
a transpiler in the most well-known one
is the PI J s projects formerly known as
pyjamas and this was one of the first
projects that try to bring pi it into
the browser so they have basically paved
the way for other projects to do the
same by at least demonstrating that this
is something that is possible it is
however a project that is well a bit
older and there are some it has some
technical depth for instance they use
browser detection and I had then they
have a different JavaScript code you
know exported JavaScript code for each
browser and that's not something that
you would do nowadays I guess flex is a
project that I spy script a project that
I am talking about more is basically a
part of and all may also mention it
later in this talk so we have these
three categories and we can compare them
using different measures for instance
how pythonic is such an approach well I
already mentioned this along the way to
some extent if you have like this
compiled into your picture this is
something that's well it's general any
point and deed JavaScript based
interpreters will be sort of quite
pythonic but there are at least in the
current implementations they are not
they don't have all the features that's
C Python has so they are not complete in
that sense and the transpiler is in this
group the least pythonic in that it's
not really part and what really
javascript that is made a lot more
platonic in terms of speed the compiled
interpreter is definitely the fastest
and the JavaScript based interpreter are
much much slower and a transpiler sits
somewhere in between depending on how
much extra
niceties or how quite onic the
transpiler is mais this piece might be
compatible or comparable which we
compiled to interpreter because it's a
JavaScript and it's so it should be
quite fast but there is some overhead
for instance if you want to make
operators behave the same way in peyten
as in this in transpiler transpile the
language you have some overhead and that
will add up and make things slower in
terms of size the transpile transpiler
projects basically have very little
extra size of course they generate
JavaScript that takes a bit more lines
of code and if you would write it
yourself but other than that there is
not nothing extra that you need and in
JavaScript
interpreters like category B you know
it's about one megabyte to a couple of
megabytes that you have to load as a
library which is depending on the
situation you might consider it as a
heavy solution or a light solution so it
depends on what you want to do with it
and the compiled interpreters are what
are heavier and you know this also again
this might be acceptable it might be not
so I think if you want to run Python in
a browser it's not enough to say I just
want to part in your browser so you have
to be more specific you I have to ask
yourself what do you want it or that and
it depends on the use case so if you
want to run the side by stack in the
browser the only way to go would be to
use a compiled interpreter like pi PI GS
simply because there's no numpy in you
know in JavaScript if you want to write
Python in a browser for educational
purposes so have a website where people
can write some code and run it just to
to learn its then the category B so the
JavaScript interpreters sort of the
pattern interpreters written in
JavaScript make a lot of sense because
they're quite lightweight and they work
however if you want to write web
application part and I think that the
main way to go is using a transpiler
based approach even though for instance
Brighton was designed to be used for
creating web applications the fact that
it's so slow I think it will prevent it
from being widely adopted and similarly
compiled interpreter could enter in
theory be used to create web
applications but it's so used you have
to wait a couple of seconds before we
can even start showing something because
you have to you know load 13 megabytes
of virtual machine and then there is
another use case where you want to
define client side interactivity in part
in for instance you have written a
certain you've done some analysis on
some data and you're exporting gets to a
visualization using some sliders and you
want to define what happens when the
user manipulates a slider I will
demonstrate some of that later on and
that is something I think that's
transpired based approaches would be
very good good about okay hmm a little
bit more about pie script so this is a
transpiler based approach if you want to
try it out you can install it using pip
or Conda and basically there's one
commands that you want to import by the
way it's it's part of Flex part of the
Flex projects but if you import it in
this way only the PI script and
transpiler is is loaded and this is the
main function and you can give it either
a string which whiten code or a function
objects or a clasp and it will give you
the corresponding JavaScript code so the
API is relative it's very simple so if
you want to play with it it's easy again
I already mentioned this to some extent
button it's just JavaScript unless
you're really just writing JavaScript
but it looks like part and so a list is
really a JavaScript array a dictionary
is a JavaScript object and floats and
ins are just JavaScript numbers and this
goods in some ways because it makes
things much faster however to make
things more pythonic all the building
functions of peyten are supported as
well as all the methods of the list
string and ticks so you can do all your
string manipulation I should use - you
can manipulate your list in dictionaries
you used to so writing in PI script is
looks a lot like peyten
also there are some JavaScript quirks so
especially if you know JavaScript you
know that there are some issues and
these are fixed in in PI script for
instance it's instance just works as you
expect it to be empty list in dictionary
if elevated falls and you can do deep
comparison so these are things that are
not the case if you just use JavaScript
however and this is I guess the big
advantage of any transpire based
projects sometimes the JavaScript shines
through and some in some cases this is
not very you know not necessarily that
bad quite harmless but it can be
annoying or unexpected especially if
you're not used to JavaScript or if you
just you know if it's not something that
you take keep in mind so are we actually
using PI scripts in a couple of projects
so I want to demonstrate these quickly
the first one is in boquete the most of
you will know bokeh is a clotting
library being followed by continuum
analytics and one thing that already was
possible for for quite a while is that
you can define maybe I should do this
thing you can define client-side
callbacks so this is a small
visualization this is official statement
with the plots and some sliders and when
the sliders are manipulated this piece
of JavaScript that we provide provides
here in this way using a multi
string will get executed in a browser to
update a figure and this is something
that already exists and a couple of
weeks ago we have made it possible to
also write it in this way so you just
define a callback in Python and this
callback is transpiled on the go and
embedded in the final plots basically
and it's being executed when the slider
is manipulated right so short
demonstration so you can manipulate the
sliders and the codes that's does this
updating of the plots is the code that
we wrote in part in another application
where PI script is used is the Flex
project so actually flexes the the
projects that started this and we need a
translation and price script is sort of
a sub projects that came out of that a
flex is sort of a GUI to toolkits that
uses web technology for its rendering
but you can simply look at it as a
server for hosting web applications
again a short example so in Flex there's
this notion where we have objects that
have a representation both in tightened
and in JavaScript and these objects are
automatically synchronized and events
are transparently sense between Python
and Java scripts and this little bit of
code shows the implementation for the
button widgets and well the interesting
part of that is that you have one class
in which you define the Python behavior
of these objects as well as the
JavaScript behavior of these objects by
writing it out in Python so these these
individual functions here are transpiled
and then compiled together to create a
parts in class that is then used
you know to create the widgets so a
small example so this is some some
weather data and we have some sliders
here and we can manipulate them and
update the plot and this this behavior
of you know when the plot when the
sliders are manipulated and and the plot
gets updated is again something that's
is implemented in using PI script so the
advantage of this is that users can very
easily define clients and interactivity
without having to learn JavaScript so
the you know the threshold to be able to
do search sort of things it's much lower
than if if users would have to write
JavaScript for that and a final use case
that I want to mention is a project
together with clinical graphics company
here in the Netherlands and we are
developing and web application for
annotating medical images and we use a
similar approach as we do in Flex where
we now have written most of the code
actually all of the code in in PI
scripts you know just scrolling through
one of the implementations we see here
an undo stack and this is a contour tool
so a tool to manipulate now I cannot
really show all the code but you see
here that there is an event terribles
crawling without a mouse so we have an
almost offense method that we implement
so events get in here this get executed
in the client and we take the
appropriate actions so to demonstrate
this where is it
and now I have to try and scroll in
zooming so this is the web application
that we've built without writing line of
of JavaScript and you can like
manipulates the contour and I don't have
time to to discuss exactly what's the
reasoning about it but you can see how
how this works more or less okay in
summary I think that we will see a lot
more projects that use patent in the
browser over the years especially when
we get webassembly there should be some
interesting things that we should be we
go seeing then also it's not that there
is like one solution to that brings pies
into the browser and serves all use
cases it's also not something that we
will have for the coming time because
you know there's different approaches
that you can do that and each each of
these categories that I mentioned has
their own use cases that that I solve
yeah that's it thank you for your
attention
we have time for questions are there any
questions about JavaScript but Python
instead
is there any performance loss if you if
you were to use what you're describing
here
you mean compared to writing it's in
JavaScript yeah in pure JavaScript yeah
yeah sure so well I already mentioned if
you write a if you use one of the
interpreters written in JavaScript these
are much much slower like a hundred
times slower than C Parton and for the
transpiler based approaches there's like
there's this big compromise that that
you have because you want to make things
very platonic but in order to do that
for instance if you want to make sure
that you can multiply a string with a
number right in patan then you repeat
the string to do to make that possible
in with a transpiler you would have to
overload the times operator that means
that everywhere on the code where
there's multiplication there is a
function called extra and that's
overhead and the more yeah the more of
these pythonic features you provide the
more overhead you create and that is
something that's you know I'm still
struggling with and also discussing with
some developers of similar projects what
one solution might be to create like a
pragmas or sort of context in which you
turn these features off so that you know
well whatever I do within this I won't
have the safety of of being helped to
make things more pythonic but at least I
know that it will be fast but that's
yeah that's a very good question that's
something that's like the compromise for
transpiler based approaches
in that case I would like to give one
more applause to our fine speaker thank
you for speaking with this lovely topic